atom ve periyodik sistem konusuna
devam ediyorduk neredeyiz periyodik
özelliklerde yiz burada nelerden
bahsedeceğim atom yarıçapı var iyonlaşma
enerjisi var elektron ilgisi var
elektronegatiflik var metalik özellik
ametalik özellik ve bunları toplu halde
güzel pratik bir yöntemle ne yapacağım
hepsini tekrar edeceğim güzel de sorular
çözeceğiz o zaman vakit kaybetmiyoruz
hazırsak başlayalım Evet bakalım İlk
başlığımız neymiş atom yarıçapı atom
yarıçapı ne demektir Aslında şöyle bir
şey ir atomun çekirdeği ile en dıştaki
elektron arasında kalan mesafeye Biz ne
diyoruz atom yarıçapı diyoruz ve Her
atomun kendine özgü bir yarıçapı olması
gerekiyor farklı atomların yarıçapları
eşit olabilir mi Hayır eşit olamaz
diyoruz genel olarak bakalım şimdi
burada Mesela işte göstermiş i de bir
atomun çekirdeği ile en dış noktadaki
elektron arasındaki mesafeye Biz atom
yarıçapı ifadesini kullanıyoruz ve şunu
bilmen gerekiyor bir Atom elektron
aldığında çapı büyür elektron verdiğinde
ise çapı küçülür Burada da bunu gösteri
işte sodyumun çapı mesela 190 Ken sodyum
elektron verdiğinde çapı küçüldü flor
atom yarıçapına İşte biz ne demişiz
burada 64 elektron aldığında ne olmuş
136 olmuş bu da önemli bir ifadedir bunu
bilmen gerekiyor tekrar hatırlatıyorum
bir Atom elektron verdiğinde çapı
küçülür elektron aldığında çapı büyür
diyoruz bir de şöyle bir ifade
kullanayım dostum Bak şöyle bir şey var
diyelim 11 kişi 11 kişiyle ip çekme
yarışması yapıyor o Oradan çekiyor o
Oradan çekiyor ne olur eşit güçte isse
Her iki taraf herhangi bir hareket olmaz
değil mi şöyle düşün Ben çekirdek
tarafıyım elektron tarafı var 11 kişi
Biz buradayız 11 kişi de orada 11
kişiden biri gitti diyelim elektron
tarafından biri gitti Ne yaparım ben
kendime doğru çekerim değil mi Ne oldu
çap küçüldü değil mi düşün bak elektron
tarafı Proton tarafı artık daha büyük
kalmış oldu Ne oldu çap küçüldü proton
sayısı değişti mi Hayır değişmedi yani
çekirdeğin çekim gücü değişti mi Hayır
değişmedi ama elektron sayısı azaldı mı
azaldı o zaman 10 tane elektron var 11
tane Proton var yani her bir elektron
başına düşen çekim gücü artmış oldu
dostum Yani şunu unutma bir Atom
elektron verdiğinde çekirdeğin çekim
gücü değişmez ama elektron başına düşen
çekim gücü arttığı için çap küçülür
tersini düşünelim şimdi bu sefer 9 tane
Proton var 9 tane elektron var tamam mı
ip çekme yarışması yapıyoruz yine bu
sefer elektron tarafına bir kişi geldi
diyelim Ne olur ben diyelim gitmek
istemiyorum sabitim ya ipi bırakmaya
başladım Ne oldu onlar çekmeye başladığı
için çap arttı yani elektron aldığında
çap Ne oldu artmış oldu dostum çekirdek
TKİ proton sayısı değişti mi Hayır
değişmedi ama elektron sayısı arttığı
için her bir elektron başına düşen çekim
gücü azalmış oldu elektron başına düşen
çekim gücü azalınca çap Ne oldu artmış
oldu işte burada da yazmışız işte
taneciklerin yarıçapları kıyaslanır Ken
neye dikkat etmem gerekiyor Öncelikle
katman sayısına dikkat etmem gerekiyor
dostum şöyle bir şey var katman sayısı
fazlaysa çap büyüktür Burada da ya da
Yarıçap büyüktür diyoruz mesela kalsiyum
ve sodyum var değil mi kalsiyuma bakar
mısın 1 2 3 4 tane katmanı var ama
sodyuma bakar mısın 1 2 3 tane katmanı
var O zaman burada şunu söyleyebilirsin
kalsiyumun yarıçapı sodyumdan daha
büyüktür yorumunu yapabilirsin katman
sayısı arttıkça çap artmaktadır Bu da
önemli bir ifadedir bir diğeri de şudur
Eğer katman sayıları aynıysa yani İkisi
de aynı katman sayısına sahipse bu
durumda da Proton sayısına bakıyorsun
proton sayısı fazla olanın çapı küçük
olacaktır hocam Ne alaka diyeceksin bak
şöyle şuraya göstereyim burada Mesela ne
vermiş 15 Proton vermiş şu tarafta da
toplamda Bak en dış 3 tane katman var ya
en dış katmanda 5 tane elektron var 15
Proton şu 5 tane elektrona çekim kuvveti
uyguluyor diğeri ne bak 12 Proton var
çekirdekte Bu da 3 katmanlı ama dışta
iki tane elektron var çok mühim değil
bak 12 Proton bu dıştaki elektronlara
çekim uyguluyor 15 Proton dıştaki
elektrona şurada bir tane elektron düşün
Bu elektrona çekim uyguluyor burada 12
Proton çekim uyguluyor e haliyle ne
olacaktır en dıştaki elektrona 15
protonun uyguladığı çekim daha fazla
olmayacak mıdır bunu şöyle de
yorumlayabilirsiniz bir tane güçlü bir
mıknatıs koydun şuraya 10 tane bilye
koydun kaç tane bilye olduğunun önemi
var mı orada yok dostum Çünkü sonuçta o
bilyeler metal bilye isse Eğer ne
olacaktır Mıknatıs tarafından
çekilecektir Mıknatıs ne kadar güçlüyse
o kadar çok çekilmeyecek mi Evet o
yüzden de aynı mantık Eğer katman
sayıları aynıysa proton sayısı büyük
olanın çapı ne olacaktır küçük olacaktır
Şimdi burada da işte bunu gösteriyor
görüyor musun İkisi de 1 2 3 kat K mana
sahip e haliyle bunun proton sayısı 15
bunun ikisi 12 o zaman magnezyumun çapı
ne olacaktır fosfordan daha büyük
olacaktır diyoruz ve Şurayı siliyorum
Bak burada da ne yazıyor periyodik
sistemde sağdan sola doğru gidildikçe ne
olacaktır atom yarıçapı artacaktır ters
yönde de azalacaktır yani şöyle bir
periyodik tablo oturtur bak şu aşağıya
şöyle bir periyodik tablo Yaparsam eğer
şöyle çizdim bu tarafa doğru çap artar
aşağıya doğru çap artar aşağıya doğru
niye artıyor Çünkü katman sayısı artıyor
E bu tarafa doğru niye artıyor Çünkü
aynı katmandaki katman sayıları aynı
proton sayısı azaldığı için son katmana
uygulanan çekim gücü azaldığı için
çapartı oluyor işte Bak burada da
gösteriyor aynı neye benzetiyoruz kardan
adam aşağıya doğru kardan adamın vücudu
gibi düşün Bu tarafa doğru da kardan
adamın burnu gibi düşünebilirsin Ne
olacak bu tarafa doğru çap azalacak
aşağıya doğru çap artacak şeklinde
söylüyoruz bunu tabii genel olarak biz a
gruplarında kullanıyoruz B gruplarından
bahsetmiyoruz bir de şu var dostum eğer
elektron sayıları aynıysa proton sayısı
büyük olanın çapı daha küçüktür Neden
Çünkü son katmanda aynı sayıda elektron
var ama proton sayısı fazlaysa
çekirdekteki proton sayısı fazlaysa
onlara daha fazla çekim uygulanmaz mı
Evet bundan dolayı çap ne olur küçülür
Burada da bunu gösteriyor bak şimdi
oksijeni vermiş 88'e -2 O zaman 10 tane
elektronu vardır hocam Ne alaka -2 ile
kaçı toplarsam 8 eder 10'u değil mi he
2'ye 8 yazdım şöyle Eee ikinciye bakalım
floru vermiş 9 demiş -1 demiş E bunun da
10 elektron elektronu var 2'ye 8 Bak
gördün mü Son katmanda İkisi de eşit
katmana sahip son katmanda eşit
elektronu var çok mühim değil sonuçta
neye bakıyoruz katman sayılarına
bakıyoruz bir de şuna bakalım sodyum
11'e + 1 + 1 dediği için 10 elektronu
var 2'ye 8 bak elektron sayıları aynı e
proton sayısı büyük olan kim burada
sodyum O zaman en fazla çekimi o
uygulayacaktır yani çapı En küçük olan
sodyum oldu sonra kim olacaktır flor
olacaktır en büyük de kim olacaktır
burada oksijen -2 olacaktır Bana da bu
sıralamayı soruyor nerede var a
seçeneğinde var dostum şu soruya bakalım
Diyor ki xa taneciğinin elektron
alışveri alışverişi sonucunda çekirdeğin
birim elektrona uyguladığı çekim kuvveti
arttığına göre bak elektron başına düşen
çekim gücü artıyor şöyle bir şeydir bak
elektron başına düşen çekim gücünü şöyle
düşünebilirsin Proton bölü elektron
şeklinde düşünebilirsin elektron başına
düşen çekim gücü artıyorsa e proton
sayısı değişmiyo o zaman çekirdeğin
uyguladığı çekim gücü değişmiyor ama
elektron başına uygulanan çekim gücü
artıyorsa Bu neden demektir elektron
sayısının azalması anlamına gelmektedir
tamam mı dostum yani elektron başına
düşen çekim gücü dediğinde Proton bölü
elektron yaz e Proton değişmeyeceğine
göre elektron sayısının nasıl
değiştiğini anlayabilirsin e burada ne
olacak Demek ki Elektron vermiş demektir
He xa taneciğinin elektron başına
uyguladığı çekim kuvveti neymiş
arttığına göre diyor katona dönüşmüştür
diyor Hım kesin değil Neden biliyor
musun şöyle bir şey var Bak x diyelim -2
di x - 1'e dönüştü örnek veriyorum e
burada Ne oldu elektron sayısı azalmadı
mı azaldı o zaman elektron başına düşen
çekim gücü artmış oldu hocam neden
azaldı Bak şöyle düşün şuraya p dersen
şurası P nedir + 2'dir şuraya bakarsan
proton sayısı aynı ya E ne olacaktır p +
1'dir Bak bu hale dönüştüğünde elektron
sayısı azalmış oldu Bundan dolayı
söylüyorum bunu işte e haliyle katona
dönüştü mü burada Hayır hala eksi yüklü
anyon olarak kalmış olabilir kesinlikle
doğrudur dediği için bu gitti çekirdeğin
çekim gücü artmıştır ya çekirdeğin çekim
gücü proton sayısı demekti bir Atom
elektron alsa da verse de proton sayısı
değişiyor muydu Hayır değişmiyo o yüzden
bunu da ne yaptık eledik Ama bir Atom
elektron alsa da verse de bunu yaptığı
anda ne olacaktır dostum kimyasal
özelliği değişecektir Yani bu kesinlikle
doğrudur cevabımız ne olacaktır yalnız 3
C seçeneği şimdi atom yarıçapını
bitirdik iyonlaşma enerjisine geçeceğiz
Ama şöyle bir atom yarıçapını tekrar
hatırlayalım neden bahsettik Dedik ki
işte çekirdekle en dıştaki elektron
arasındaki mesafeyi Evet Periyodik
tabloda nereden nereye doğru artıyordu
1A grubuna doğru artıyordu ve Aynı
grupta aşağıya doğru artıyordu yani
katman sayısı arttıkça artıyordu o zaman
katman sayısı büyük olanın yarıçapı
büyüktür yorumunu yapabiliriz Aynı
grupta ve aynı periyotta bahsediyorsak
proton sayısı küçük olanın çapı büyüktür
ifadesini kullanıyorduk ve şu vardı bir
Atom elektron aldığında çapı artıyordu
elektron verdiğinde çapı küçülüyordu bu
ifadeleri kullandık Eğer elektron
sayıları aynıysa proton sayısı büyük
olanın çapı küçüktür yorumunda ne
yapıyoruz Yapıyoruz dostum o zaman
iyonlaşma enerjisine geçebiliriz
iyonlaşma enerjisi ne demektir
tanımından bahsedelim önce gaz halinde
deki bak burası önemli bir atomdan
elektron koparmak için verilmesi gereken
enerjiye Biz iyonlaşma enerjisi diyoruz
Eğer Nötr atomdan bir elektron
koparıyorsun bu birinci iyonlaşma
enerjisidir + 1 yüklü den bir elektron
koparıyorsun daha önce bir tane kopmuş
demektir + 1'den elektron koparıyorsun +
2'ye dönüşecek ya Yani atomun ikinci
elektronunu koparıyor demektir O da
ikinci iyonlaşma enerjisidir + 2'den
elektron koparıyorsun 3üncü iyonlaşma
enerjisi oluyor burada da bunu
gösteriyor işte bak gaz halinde nötr
atom bir elektron kopardık birinci
iyonlaşma enerjisi gaz halinde Art bir
yüklü bundan bir elektron kopardık +
2'ye dönüştürdük yani ikinci elektronunu
kopardık atomun Bu da ikinci iyonlaşma
enerjisi Ama şuna bak Gaz halindeki nötr
atom burada ne olmuş x + 2'ye dönüşmüş
yani 2 elektron birden kopmuş 2 elektron
burayı Ben tamamlıyorum 2 elektron
birden koptuğunu göre bu birinci
iyonlaşma enerjisi de değil ikinci
iyonlaşma enerjisi de değil Peki Bu ne
biliyor musun dostum bu 1 ile 2nin
toplamı bak Bu ikisini toplarsan Eğer
Neyi vermiş oluyor Hatta şuna E3 diyelim
E3 de demeye bilil biriz buna e de diye
İriz fark etmez E ne olacak dostum
burada birinci ve ikinci yon laşma
enerjilerinin toplamı olacak ve bu değer
bu değer ne demektir i1 + i2 şeklinde
olacaktır dostum şu vardır bir atomdan
elektron kopardıkça elektron başına
uygulanan çekim gücü artıyor demiştik ya
o zaman bir sonraki elektronu koparmak
için daha fazla enerji vermek gerekir Bu
da şu demektir bir atomun her iyonlaşma
enerjisi bir öncekine göre daha büyük
olacaktır Yani birinci yon laşma
enerjisi en küçüktür ikinci daha
büyüktür 3 daha daha büyüktür böyle
gider bu şekilde artarak gitmektedir
Hatta bu aralarındaki artış oranı var ki
ona da birazdan geleceğim dostum
önemlidir bu işte Atom elektron verdikçe
elektron başına düşen çekim gücü artar
diyor Bundan dolayı ne olacaktır bir
sonraki iyonlaşma eni daha büyük
olacaktır diye de yazmışız işte Heh sana
söylediğim şey burada İşte bu birbirini
takip eden iyonlaşma enerjilerine
bakıyorsun birinci iyonlaşma enerjisi
ikinci iyonlaşma enerjisi 3 4 5 diye
gidiyor Şimdi burada birbirini takip
eden iyonlaşma Enerjileri arasındaki
artış farkı böyle ciddi iyi bir
şekildeyse minimum 3,5 4 kat veya daha
fazlaysa biz buraya işaret koyuyoruz
Çünkü orada atom artık soygaza benzemiş
demektir yani soygaza benzediğinden
dolayı da bir kararlılık kazanmıştır
oradan elektron koparmak zorlaşır Bak bu
atom birinci yön aşma enerjisinden sonra
ciddi bir artış gerçekleştiriyor Şuraya
bak ne yapmış bir çizgi çekmişiz işaret
koymuşuz işte Demek ki bu bu atom bir
elektron verdikten sonra soygaza
benziyor E bu da 1A grubu elementi
olması demektir 1 A grubu bir elektron
verdiğinde artık soy soy gaza
benzemektedir değil mi Son katmanda bir
elektronu vardı ya onu verdi E ne oldu
soygaza benzedi O yüzden de 1 ile 2
arasında böyle ciddi bir artış varsa 1A
grubu elementidir diyebilirsin Şuna
bakar mısın Berilyum diyor burada
birinci elektronu verdi sonra iki katına
yakın bir artış var Tamam çok güzel ama
sonra ne oluyor 14.000 küsur ciddi bir
artış var görüyor musun 2 elektron
verdikten sonra soygaza benzemiş
demektir Bu da 2A grubu elementi
anlamına gelmektedir Eğer bu artış 3 ile
4 arasında olursa 3A grubu 4 ile 5
arasında olursa 4A grubu diyelim ilk
5'inde yok İlk 5'inde yoksa şurada bir
yerde olabilir değil mi yani 5 le 6
arasında olabilir 6 ile 7 arasında
olabilir mesela 5 ile 6 arasında olsa
biz buna 5A grubu diyeceğiz ama nerede
olduğunu bilmiyorum değil mi ilk 5'ini
verdi ve o istediğimiz artış yok veya
ilk dördünü verdi istediğimiz artış yok
mesela Burası için şunu söyleyebilirim
Buradan sonra bir yerde olursa en az 5A
grubu elementi ifadesini kullanabilirim
dostum İşte burada Bak ne olacaktır
lityum 1A grubu elementi Berilyum 2A
grubu elementi burada alüminyuma bakar
mısın Burada yok istediğimiz artış 3 kat
gibi e burada da yok ama burada ciddi
bir artış var 3A grubu elementi veya
Şuna bak burada istediğimiz artış yok
Burada da istediğimiz artış Yok burada
da yok ama bak Görüyor musun Ciddi bir
artış var 4356 danan 16.000 küsur ciddi
bir artış var haliyle ne olacaktır Bu da
4A grubu elementi olacaktır bu şekilde
anlayabiliriz dostum ve şöyle bir şey
var burada lityumla ilgili bir şey
söyleyeyim lityuma bakar mısın birinci
elektronunu verd Bak şöyle 2ci elektronu
verdi 3 elektronu verdi sonrasındaki
çizgiler ne demek biliyor musun
elektronu kalmamış demek eğer sana bir
tablo verdiyse ve bu şekilde böyle boş
yerler gözüküyorsa o kadar elektronu
vardır demektir 1 2 3 elektronu vardır O
zaman direkt elektron dizil dizilişi
2'ye 1 şeklinde söyleyebiliriz veya
burada Berilyum 1 2 3 4 var 5'incisi boş
değil mi o zaman Berilyum da 2ye 2
şeklinde yazılabilir değil mi Ama
alüminyum a 5 tane varmış o zaman Bu da
2'ye 3 mü Ne bileyim ben bunun devamı
olup olmadığını bilmiyorum ki bundan
dolayı bu böyle olmaz işte şöyle isse
bir boş çizgi görüyorsan bunun elektron
sayısını belirleyebilirsin ama şöyle
olursa devamı olabilir onunla ilgili
yorum yapamazsın dostum şu var dostum
taneciklerin iyonlaşma enerjisi
kıyaslanır Ken kurallarımız var ilk
kuralımız şudur önce son katmandaki
elektron sayısına bakacağız yani
değerlik elektron sayısına bakacağız
değerlik elektron sayısı büyük olanın
iyonlaşma enerjisi genellikle büyük
olacaktır genellikle diyorum Çünkü bazı
istisnaları var Onları da söyleyeceğim
Mesela bak ben burada karbon ve sodyumu
kıyaslarsan eğer sodyumun K 2 8 1 son
katmanda 1 elektronu var Karbonun K ise
2'ye 4 4 elektronu var o zaman Karbonun
birinci iyonlaşma enerjisi sodyumun Ken
büyüktür yorumunu ne yapabilirim
yapabilirim Eğer son katmandaki elektron
sayıları eşitse yani Aynı gruptayız bu
durumda da çapı büyük olanın ya da
katman sayısı büyük olanın iyonlaşma
enerjisi daha küçüktür sebebi ise şu
katman sayısı büyük olunca son
katmandaki elektronu koparmak daha kolay
olur Neden Çünkü katman sayısı fazlaysa
çekirdeğin O son katman uyguladığı çekim
düşüyor E bundan dolayı çapı küçük
olanın ne olacaktır iyonlaşma enerjisi
daha büyük olacaktır Burada da onu
söylüyor işte bak ikisinin de son
katmanında Beşer elektron var ama bu iki
katmanlı bu 3 katmanlı e haliyle Bu ne e
azotun k fosfordan daha büyüktür
yorumunu yapabiliriz Ama dedim ya bak bu
genelleme diye son katmandaki elektron
sayısına dikkat ettiğimizde 5A 6a Bir de
2A 3A da bir değişiklik vardır Onu da
şurada söylüyoruz dostum 2A 3A danan
daha büyüktür 5A da 6a A'dan daha
büyüktür Çünkü 2 A'da ve 5 A'da küresel
simetri vardır küresel simetri özelliği
varsa Kendisinden bir sonraki gruba göre
daha yüksek iyonlaşma enerjisine sahip
oluyorlar Bu kuralı sakın unutma Eğer
bak genelleme ile gitseydik şöyle bir
şey olacaktı Şuradaki boşluğa yapacağım
1 A'nın en küçük sonra 2A sonra 3A sonra
4A sonra 5A sonra 6a 7A ve 8A olacaktı
ama küresel simetri olduğu için şöyle
renk değiştiriyorum şu şunla şu yer
değiştiriyor yani 3 aşağıya gidiyor
Şununla da şu yer değiştiriyor 5 yukarı
gidiyor ve sıralamamız şu oluyor 1A 3A
2A 4A 5A ne Pardon 6a 5A 7A 8A şeklinde
oluyor biz buna 3 aşağı 5 yukarı kuralı
diyoruz dostum tamam mı Yani 5A 6 A'dan
büyük 2A da 3 A'dan büyük O yüzden de
grafiğimiz şöyle oluyor bak dostum
görüyor musun 1 A'dan sonra şurası 1A
grubu elementi 2A geliyor 2A da artıyor
3A nın K bundan küçük görüyor musun
aşağı düşüyor sonra 4A geliyor 5A ıni
artıyor 6a da düşüyor 7A 8A şeklinde
gidiyor Burada çok benzeyen birbirine
çok benzeyen yerler var görüyor musun
Eğer soruda sana şöyle bir şekil verirse
Bak şöyle çizeyim şuraya Heh şu şekilde
da düz ol Heh çizdim iyonlaşma enerjisi
atom numarası diye bir grafik verdi sana
şöyle bir görsel verirse dostum burada
dikkat etmen gereken nokta buna x buna y
Buna da Z atomları dedi Dedi ki Tom
numaraları ardışık x y z için nay nay
nay hangileri doğrudur falan diye bir
soru sordu yeşil yapacağım mesela x'e 1A
grubu diyebilirim Çok güzel Y'ye 2A
grubu diyebilirim Z'ye de 3A grubu
diyebilirim ama kesin midir değildir
şöyle de olabilir böyle verdiğinde
Burası 4A grubu şurası 5A grubu şurası
6a grubu da olabilir bununla ilgili
böyle istisnai sorular gelebilir ama
burada kesin olan bir şey vardır ki Y
nedir küresel simetri özelliği gösterir
2A da olsa 5A da olsa bu grafiğe bakarak
şunu söyleyebilirsin zıplamalar olduğu
yerlerde küresel simetri özelliği vardır
diyebiliriz dostum gel şimdi örneklere
bakalım Diyor ki sodyum flor ve lityum
elementlerinin birinci iyonlaşma
enerjilerini kıyaslamam istiyor sodyum
11 2 8 1 flor var 9 2'ye 7 ne var lityum
var 3 2'ye 1 ne demiştik önce Grup
numarasına bakıyorduk bu 1A grubu bu 7A
grubu Bu da 1A grubu 7A grubunun
iyonlaşma enerjisi 1A grubundan büyüktü
o zaman iyonlaşma enerjisi flor en büyük
olacaktır şimdi şu da 1A grubu şu da 1A
grubu Aynı grupta ne yapıyorduk çapı
küçük olanın yani katman sayısı az
olanın neydi iyonlaşma enerjisi Daha
büyüktü yani lityum en küçük de ne oldu
burada sodyum oldu o zaman felina felina
felina nerededir cevabımız a seçeneğidir
tablomu bakalım bana güzel bir tablo
vermiş diyor ki baş Grup elementi olan
ve iyonlaşma enerj enerjisi değerleri kj
B mol cinsinden verilen atomlarla ilgili
hangileri doğrudur diye soruyor şimdi
şuna bakarsak bunların arasında
istediğimiz artış yok Ama şundan
sonrasının boş olduğunu görüyor musun
Yani x 2 tane elektronu olan nötr halde
de 2 protonu olan elementtir bu da 2
Yani bu 8A grubudur 1 periyot 8A helyum
elementinden bahsediyor şimdi şuna
bakalım 1400 küsur 2800 küsür Yani iki
katlık bir artış var burada da ya iki
kat bile yok burada var mı o yok Evet
ilk dördünde istediğim artış yok o zaman
şunla sonra bir yerde olabilir yani Y
için ne diyebiliriz en az 4A grubu
elementi diyebiliriz şimdi şuna bakalım
700 küsür 1400 2 kat 1400 küsür 7.000
küsur ha bak istediğimiz artış var Z
için 2A grubu elementi diyebiliriz t'ye
bakalım tde 500 küsur 1000 küsur 2 kat
gibi burada 1000 küsur 4900 var
istediğim artış var burada o zaman bu da
2A grubu elementidir Bunu da belirttik
çok güzel diyor ki x soygazdan bariz
belli buradan gözüküyor helyum olduğu
için bunu yapıştırdık şimdi Z ve t ile
ilgili bunların Aynı grupta olduğunu
görüyor muyuz İkisi de 2A grubu elementi
değil mi şöyle bir şey vardır Aynı
grupta iyonlaşma enerjisi ne oluyordu
çapla ters orantılı yani çapı büyük
olanın iyonlaşma enerjisi küçük çapı
küçük olanın iyonlaşma enerjisi büyüktü
şimdi ikisi de 2A grubu elementi
olduğuna göre iyonlaşma enerjisi büyük
olan Z olduğuna göre çapı küçük olan Z
olmalı çap aşağıya doğru arttığı için Z
yukarıda olmalı T de aşağıda olmalı He
bakalım şimdi Z'nin çapı t'nin kinden
büyüktür Hayır küçüktür yanlıştır Çünkü
çapla iyonlaşma enerjisi ters orantılı
ydı Aynı grupta y'nin değerlik elektron
sayısı en az 4'tür en az 4A grubu olduğu
için bu ifadeyi ne yapabilirim
kullanabilirim cevabım 1 ve 3 oldu yani
C seçeneği bir sonraki sorumuza geçelim
bakalım ne diyor Yukarıdaki periyodik
sistemde yerleri belirtilen element
atomları ile ilgili aşağıdaki
ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır diyor Hım
bana bazı elementler vermiş bak Z'yi
vermiş ya Z'nin olduğu yer bizim için
çok önemli Hemen onun hidrojen olduğunu
belirtelim hidrojen 1 grubunda ama metal
değil alkali metal değil [__] metaldir
önemli bir ayrıntı onu belirtmek lazım
Bir de burada y'yi vermiş y'nin de
helyum olduğunu unutmayalım Bu da önemli
bir ayrıntı bakalım şimdi diyor ki Z'nin
Grup numarası ile atom numarası aynıdır
Z 1A grubu elementi e atom numarası
hidrojen olduğu için 1 Evet Grup
numarasıyla ne aynı atom numarası
aynıdır Doğrudur diyor ki 1 yon aşma
enerjisi en büyük olan yd doğru çünkü
iyonlaşma enerjisi bu tarafa doğru ve
yukarıya doğru arttığında karşımıza kim
denk geliyor helyum denk geliyor
Doğrudur at atom çapı en büyük olan xir
atom çapı ne tarafa doğru artıyordu renk
değiştirerek gösteriyorum dostum bu
tarafa doğru ve aşağıya doğru artıyor
bunların arasında kim denk geldi x denk
geldi o yüzden bu da doğru bir ifadedir
diyor ki t elementinden bir elektron
koparmak için verilmesi gereken enerji
x' ininden büyüktür bir elektron
koparmak için verilmesi gereken enerjiye
Biz Ne diyorduk iyonlaşma enerjisi
diyorduk Yani şunu söylüyor 3A grubunda
olan t'nin 2A grubundaki x'ten daha
yüksek iyonlaşma enerjisine sahip
olduğunu söylüyor y yanlıştır 2A
grubunun iyonlaşma enerjisi 3 A'dan
büyüktü O yüzden Aynı periyotta bu
yanlış bir ifadedir diyor ki Z2 ve y oda
koşullarında homojen karışım oluşturur y
helyumdan Bu da gaz halindedir gazların
oluşturduğu karışımlar her zaman
homojendir o yüzden doğru bir ifadedir
biz yanlışı bulduk cevabımız D
seçeneğidir güzel bir soru daha var
diyor ki periyodik sistemde ikinci
periyotta bulunan ve atom numaraları
ardışık olan neymiş birin yon aşma
Enerjileri verilen bir tablo verilmiş bu
tabloda dikkat et x'i y'yi kyi ve Z'yi
göstermiş atom numaraları ardışık dediği
şu şöyle şöyle şöyle şöyle gidiyor bir
tablo vermiş bu tabloda x y k ve z var
Gördüğün gibi diyor ki Buna göre
aşağıdaki ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır
diye soruyor değerlik elektron sayısı en
fazla olan ZD diyor hemen belirtelim bak
dostum bu 1A grubu elementi bu 2A grubu
elementi Burası 3A şöyle 4A 5A var
burada k'ye 6a denk geldi bu 7A Bu da 8A
Evet değerlik elektron sayısı en büyük
olan kim burada ZD Çünkü 8A grubu
elementi doğru y elementi Toprak alkali
metalidir diyor Toprak alkali 2A grubu
Evet y de 2A grubu elementi olduğu için
doğrudur tamamı metaldir diyor Bir
dakika x 1A grubunda metal diyeceksin
hocam hidrojen olamaz mı ya olamaz
ikinci periyotta çünkü bunlar E o zaman
bu lityum gibi düşünebiliriz Tamam x
metal y de metal Eyvallah z ne şey
burada ne var Z 8A grubu elementi soygaz
e k de 6a grubunda ametal Demek ki
tamamı metaldir ifadesi yanlış oldu
diyor ki K elementi kalkojenler
grubundadır yani 6a grubundadır Doğrudur
Z elementi oda koşullarında tek atomlu
gaz halindedir Soygazlar oda
koşullarında tek atomlu gaz halinde
bulunur ifadesi doğruydu Biz yanlışı
bulduk cevabımız C seçeneğidir Hadi
bakalım şimdi soru çözme zamanı bakalım
ne diyor bana ne vermiş iki tane atom
vermiş Pardon tanecik vermiş Ee Bununla
ilgili olarak hangileri doğrudur x'e
bakar mısın X'in toplamda 13 protonu var
ama Şurayı saydığımda 10 tane elektronu
var yani 2'ye 8 Eyvallah Y'ye bakalım
haliyle bunun da yükünün ne olması lazım
+ 3 olması lazım Y'ye bakarsak 9 protonu
var sayıyorum burayı 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
mu oldu he E ne oldu nötr müş bu çok
güzel 2'ye 7 olarak da bunu belirttik
çok güzel diyor ki X ve y'nin
yarıçapları eşittir diyor e Hayır
değildir bir kere şöyle bir durum var
dostum 13 Proton var 10 elektronu var 9
Proton var 9 elektronu var E katman
sayısı aynı katman sayıları aynı
olduğunda E ne olacak proton sayısı
büyük olanın çapı daha küçük olacak yani
burada y'nin çapı x + 3'ten daha büyük
olacağı için bu ne oldu yanlış oldu
diyor ki birer elektron koparmak için
x'e verilmesi gereken enerji y'nin
kinden fazladır diyor şöyle bir şey
vardı eğer katman sayıları aynı e
baktığımızda bu 13 Proton 10 elektronu
çekiyor yani Proton bölü elektron oranı
elektron başına uygulanan çekim gücü
daha fazla Bundan dolayı x'e verilmesi
gereken enerji daha fazladır doğru
Doğrudur diyor ki x katyon y ise nötrdür
Evet doğrudur çünkü x + 3 yüklü y ise
Elektron ve proton sayısı eşit olduğu
için nötr Doğrudur biz yanlışı mı
arıyoruz doğruları arıyoruz cevabımız D
seçeneği olacak dostum 2'ye bakalım
şöyle dur renk de değiştireceğim Heh 2de
diyor ki Aşağıda verilen elementlerden
hangisinin birinci iyonlaşma enerjisi
daha büyüktür iyonlaşma enerjisi neydi
Grup numarası arttıkça genellikle
artıyordu yani 8 A'nın en büyüktü sonra
7A sonra 5A 6a diye gidiyordu
Hatırlarsan şimdi 8A güzel başka bu 7A
bir tane daha 8A var şimdi şunları o
zaman eleyelim Çünkü son katmandaki
elektron sayısı en büyük olan yani 8
olanların K Daha büyüktü peki iki tane 8
olan var bu durumda ne yapıyorduk son
katmandaki elektron sayısı yani değerlik
elektron sayıları eşitse bu durumda da
katman sayısı az olan ya da çapı küçük
olanın iyonlaşma enerjisi daha büyüktür
diyorduk E bu 3 katmanlı bu iki katmanlı
O zaman cevap D seçeneği olacak dostum
3ün soruya geldik diyor ki periyodik
sistemde ilk 4 periyodun A gruplarında
bulunan x y z ve t elementlerinin kesit
gösterimi yukarıda verilmiştir Tamam
verilmiş Peki ne ilk 4 periyodun A
gruplarında ilk dör periyotta Tamam öyle
dursun bakalım şimdi atom çapı en büyük
olan yd atom çapı bu tarafa doğru ve
aşağıya doğru arttığında karşımıza y
denk geliyor Yani doğru bir ifadedir
diyor ki y ve T alaşım
oluşturabiliyorsunuz değerlik elektron
sayısı 7 olamaz Hım şu var y ve T alaşım
oluşturuyorsa metal olmak zorunda yani T
7A grubunda olursa olmaz ilk dör
periyotta T elementi ne olmak zorunda
ametal olmak zorunda o yüzden Z 7A
grubunda olabilir mi olamaz O yüzden bu
ifade Doğrudur diyor ki Z'nin birinci
iyonlaşma enerjisi x' ininden küçüktür
diyor Z'nin iyonlaşma enerjisi x'
ininden nasıl küçük olabilir bu 6a grubu
olur Bu da 5A grubu olur o zaman aynı
periyotta 5 A'nın iyonlaşma yanası 6
A'dan büyük olduğu için bu ifade
olabilir mi Evet olabilir cevap Ne oldu
e seçeneği oldu 4 sorumuza geldik diyor
ki periyodik sistemde baş Grup
elementleri olan x y z elementlerinden y
ve z Aynı grupta X ve Y ise aynı
periyottadır diyor Hım şöyle bakalım şu
şekilde belirtelim şöyle çizdim Bak
şimdi diyor ki y ve z Aynı grupta X ve Y
aynı periyotta şöyle yazalım mesela y ve
z x ile de y Şöyle mesela olabilir Daha
birçok ihtimal var Mesela şöyle bir
ihtimal de söz konusu x burada olur y ve
z böyle de olabilir mesela Bakalım şimdi
diyor ki y'nin birinci yoğunlaşma
enerjisi en büyüktür kesin mi değil
Çünkü y bu tarafta mı bu tarafta mı
Kesin bir bilgim yok bundan dolayı
birinci hakkında kesin yorum yapamam
atom numarası en büyük olan xir diyor
şöyle bir şey var biz mesela böyle
çizdik de şöyle çizemez miydik şu
şekilde mesela çizdim diyelim x'i buraya
yaptım y ve Pardon şöyle y ve z böyle de
yapamaz mıyım yapabilirim yani y'nin en
büyük olabilir veya şöyle çizsem x
Burada olsa y burada Z burada E bu da
olabilir bu sefer xin en büyük olabilir
Yani kesin bir durum var mı Yok onu da
eledik diyor ki Z Toprak alkali metali
ise yani Ne demek bu Z 2A
grubundayım Bak şimdi diyelim 2A
grubunda Z buradaymış diyelim tamam y
oda koşullarında katı halde bulunur e y
ile Z Aynı grupta değil miydi yani y de
burada olmak zorunda yani y de metal
olmak zorunda E bundan dolayı oda
koşullarında 2A grupu elementleri katı
halde bulunduğu için üçüncüsü kesinlikle
doğrudur cevap da ne oldu B seçeneği
oldu 5 sorumuza geldik diyor ki x 17'nin
3 tane iyonunu vermiş bana bunların
yarıçaplarının toplamda 20 elektron oldu
ilginç bir örnek olmuş x'e bakalım bu 17
bu + 5 demiş hım çok güzel Bunu da şöyle
diyelim mesela şurası da ne olur 12 olur
e x 17'ye -1 18 oldu ne demiştik proton
sayıları aynı olduğunda elektron sayısı
büyük olanın çapı büyüktür Çünkü
elektron başına uygulanan çekim kuvveti
düşüyor ya da şöyle düşün bir Atom
elektron aldıkça çapı artıyordu elektron
verdikçe yarıçapı azalıyordu E o zaman
elektron sayısı en büyük olan x -3
olduğu için çapı en büyük olan x -3
sonra x -1 sonra da x + 5 olmalı cevap
da C seçeneği olmalı bu teorik bir soru
zaten Yani x 17'ye -3 aldıramıyorum
tabii ki ama bu teorik bir soru olduğu
için bunu yorumlayabiliriz 6 soruya
bakalım bana ne ver vermiş Yukarıdaki
periyodik sistemin baş grubunda yer alan
a b c d elementlerinin iyonlaşma
enerjisi tablosu verilmiştir diyor buna
göre hangisi yanlıştır diye soruyor
şimdi 493 4500 küsür Aha ciddi bir artış
var 1 ile 2 arasında Olduğunda biz buna
1A grubu elementi diyorduk B'ye bakalım
589 1000 küsur 2 kat civarı ama burada
ciddi bir artış var demek ki B de 2A
grubu elementi olacaktır çok güzel
buraya bakalım C elementine bakar mısın
C elementi 518 ciddi Bak bu 7000 O zaman
bu da 1A grubu elementi ama C için şunu
da söyleyebilirim bak 4C bir elektronu
Yok ya C şudur Aslında 3 elektronu
vardır Çünkü toplamda 3 tane iyonlaşma
enerjisi varsa 3 elektronu vardır
diyebilirsin 2'ye birdir Aslında bunu
belirtebiliriz devam ediyorum D elementi
ne olmuş 800 2400 küsür 3 kat civarı Ama
bak burada 25.000 küsur çıkıyor yani bu
da 3A grubu elementidir Hım şimdi çok
dikkatli dinle Ne yapacağım biliyor
musun B'den başlayarak gideceğim a'yı
sona bırakıyorum muhteşem bir soru Çünkü
bak diyor ki A alkali metaldir Evet
doğrudur e Ama hocam hidrojen olamaz mı
1A grubunda diyorsun y hidrojen olsa bir
tane elektron olduğu için bir tane
iyonlaşma enerjisi olması gerekiyor
Burada 2 var 3 var 4 var Yani bu 1A
grubunda Ama birinci periyotta değildir
yani hidrojen olamaz hidrojen değilse
alkali metaldir O yüzden a alkali
metaldir ifadesi kesinlikle doğrudur
diyor ki C elementi periyodik sistemde
atom numarası En küçük olan metaldir
Doğrudur Çünkü 2'ye 1 ya Yani 2ci
periyot 1A grubu alkali metalidir doğru
ondan önce ne var 2 var yani helyum
soygaz ondan önce 1 var hidrojen ondan
öncekiler ya ametal ya soygaz Yani ilk
metal bu O yüzden doğru bir ifadedir
diyor ki A'nın çapı C'nin kinden
büyüktür ne diyor büyüktür diyor Evet
şimdi Aynı grupta ne demiştik iyonlaşma
enerjisi büyükse çap küçüktü Şimdi
bakıyoruz 493 518 Demek ki C burada A da
burada olmalı yani A'nın çapı daha büyük
olmalı iyonlaşma yisi daha küçük olduğu
için aynı gruptakileri kıyaslarsan
burada o yüzden Doğrudur değerlik
elektron sayısı en büyük olan DD dir
doğru çünkü 3A grub elementi değerlik
elektron sayısı 3'tür gelelim A'ya sanki
şöyle düşünüyorsun birisi 2A grubu
birisi 3A grubu o zaman bunlar aynı
periyotta olabilir Ne olacak sanki
sonuçta biri 2A biri de 3A Ama şöyle bir
şey var aynı periyotta olsa 2A nn
iyonlaşma enerjisi 3A danan büyük olması
lazım ama bunun ikisi 589 bunun ikisi
800 Aha 3A grubundaki demek daha büyük
Bu da şu anlama geliyor demek ki
periyodu küçük periyodu çok küçük olduğu
için mesela 3 A'daki bir element 2
A'daki büyük Olabilir mi Olabilir ama
kesin olmayacak bir şey söyleyeyim
bunlar aynı periyotta olamaz aynı
periyotta olsaydı 2 a'nın daha büyük
olurdu o yüzden burada cevabımız A
seçeneğidir çok ince Çok klas bir soru
dostum 7 soruya geldik diyor ki X ve Y
periyodik sistemde farklı gruplarda
bulunan baş Grup elementlerdir Peki öyle
olsun Buna göre bu elementlerin
niceliklerinden hangileri kesinlikle
aynı olamaz diyor Hım neymiş farklı
gruplarda bulunan A grubu elementleri
baş Grup A grubu elementi ya şimdi
periyodik sistemde grupları farklı
periyotları aynı olamaz mı birisi ikinci
periyot 2 birisi 2 periyot 5A Olamaz mı
olabilir yani bu aynı olabilir aynı
olabilir diyor ki değerlik elektron
sayıları aynı olabilir desem hocam nasıl
ya biri 8A olsa birisi 2A olsa birinimi
8 birinimi 2 oluyor Yani kesin aynı
olmaz ya bunlar diye düşünüyorsun Ama
mesela ben buna helyum desem 2 değerlik
elektron sayısı 2 Evet 8A grubu ama
değerlik elektron sayısı 2 Buna da
mesela şey desem Berilyum desem 4 2'ye 2
bak değerlik elektron sayısı 2 ama 2A
grubu elementinde farklı gruplar ama
değerlik elektron sayıları eşit Yani
kesin aynı olamaz diyemem buna aynı
olabilir ama atom çapı Sonuçta farklı
elementlerin atom çapı asla aynı olamaz
kesinlikle aynı olamaz aradığımız için
cevabımız B seçeneği olacaktır 8
sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki Z'nin 1 yş
mayası x' ininden büyüktür y'nin nükleon
sayısı x' ininden küçüktür diyor
periyodik sistemde 3 periyotta bulunan x
y z elementleri ile ilgili bilgiler
veriyormuş Şimdi şöyle bir şey var
çizelim ihtimaller Dünyası değil mi
Burası şöyle yaptım mesela diyor ki
Z'nin birin yon aşma enerjisi x' ininden
büyük mesela Z burada olsun x burada
olsun örnek veriyorum 7A grubu 6a grubu
gibi diyor ki y'nin nükleon sayısı x'
ininden küçük yani y burada olabilir
değil yükle numarası 1 A'ya doğru
azalıyor gibi düşünebiliriz Proton ve
nötronun toplamı ya Y genelleme olarak
söyleyebiliriz O zaman böyle
baktığımızda y'nin çapı en büyük sonra x
sonra Z böyle bir şey var mı y x z var
gibi Peki başka ihtimal olamaz mıydı
diyeceksin ki ya hocam şöyle bir şey
vardı Sonuçta Z'nin birinci anlaşma
enerjisi X'in kinden büyük olduğu için
örnek veriyorum Z'ye Ben 5A grubu
elementi desem x'e 6a grubu desem mesela
y de böyle olsa olamaz mı bu da olabilir
doğru yani y ZX de olabilir ama şıklarda
böyle bir şey var mı Yok olabiliri
sorduğu için biz Neyi arıyoruz yxz Cevap
da ne oldu D seçeneği oldu dostum 99'a
bakalım Diyor ki elektron katman
dizilimi yukarıda verilen x y z element
atomları ile ilgili ifadelerinden
hangileri doğrudur diye bir şey sormuş
bakalım şimdi atom çapı en büyük olan ZD
1 2 3 4 katmanlı 1 2 3 katmanlı 1 2 3
katmanlı katman sayısı arttıkça çap
artıyordu O yüzden Z'nin çapı en
büyüktür tak diye doğruyu işaretledikten
A'dan büyüktü aynı periyotta Bunlar da 1
A'dan büyük oluyordu çünkü hem çapı
büyük hem de periyodu küçük o yüzden
Z'nin en küçük olacak yani sıralamam y
bü Pardon x ü y b z olmalıydı burada ne
demiş yxz demiş gitti bir o istisnayı
göz ardı etmiş demiş ki Z elementi Z
elementi X ve Y ile iyonik bağlı bileşik
oluşturabilir e Bunlar ametal 5A ve 6a
grubu 3 periyotta Bunlar ametal E bu da
metal e metalle ametal arasında iyonik
bağlı bileşik oluşabilir Doğrudur cevap
1 3 olmalı yani C seçeneği 10 sorumuza
bakalım katman Elektron dizilimlerini
vermiş bana nötr x yz için sorular
soruyor şimdi art1 yüklü hali buysa yani
18 elektronu varsa nötr X'in 19
elektronu olacaktır 19 da protonu
olacaktır yani nötr halde 2 8 8 1'dir
Y'ye bakalım -3 yüklü halinde 10
elektronu var 2 8 daha 10 E o zaman y ne
olacaktır nötr halde 7 olacaktır 2'ye 5
Z'ye bakalım -1 yüklü hali 18' mii o
zaman nötr hali 17 olacak şöyle Z'yi de
yazalım h z 17 2 8 7 olacak şimdi
bakalım X ve z aynı periyottadır Şimdi x
4 periyotta Hatta şöyle yazalım 4
periyot 1A grubu z ne olacaktır 3
periyot 7A grubu y ise 2 periyot 5A
grubu olacaktır E o zaman X ve z aynı
periyottadır yanlış y'nin çekirdek yükü
yani proton sayısı 10'dur Hayır bu nedir
7'dir görüyorsun burada görüldüğü gibi x
alkali metaldir Evet 1A grubu elementi
olduğu için doğrudur ama devam edelim 1
iyonlaşma yisi En küçük olan ZD diyor
Hayır en büyük olan odur Çünkü 7A grubu
elementi O yüzden gitti periyodik
sistemde X'in bulunduğu periyottaki tüm
elementler baş Grup elementidir diyor
Bakalım X'in bulunduğu periyot X'in
bulunduğu periyot 4 periyot 4 periyotta
B grupları da vardır yani yan Grup
elementleri de vardır O yüzden gitti
cevabımız nedir c seçeneğidir 11
sorumuza geldik bana bir tane ne vermiş
şekil vermiş bir iyonlaşma enerjisi atom
numarası grafiği atom numaraları Ardışık
ne atomları vermiş baş Grup elementi
Şimdi x burada 1A gruba elementi
olabilir şöyle Yazalım bakalım 1A grubu
oldu bu o zaman 2A grubu olacaktır Bu da
3A grubu olacaktır Peki başka ihtimal
yok mu var bu 4A grubu olabilir bu 5A
grubu olabilir bu da 6a grubu olabilir
şimdi bakalım kesinlikle doğrudur
soruyor x alkali metaldir kesin değil 4A
grubu elementi de olabilir X ve Y aynı
periyotta Z farklı periyottadır y
yanlıştır Çünkü şöyle bir şey var Bu
görüntü 2A Pardon 1A 2A 3A da ya da 4A
5A 6a da vardır yani üçü de aynı
periyotta olacaktır şöyle olsaydı dediği
doğru olurdu şöyle olsaydı 7A 8A 1A
şeklinde derdik farklı periyotta
olduğunu söylerdik ama bu değil diyor ki
x yarı metal ise x yarı metal x hangi
durumda yarı metal olabilir silisyum
olduğunda yani 4A grubu olduğunda yarım
metal is Z'nin değerlik elektron sayısı
artırır Yani bu 4A olursa Z 6a olur evet
bu kesin doğru oldu Gördüğün gibi
değerlik elektron sayıları toplamı 6 ise
E şimdi bak 1A 2A 3A değerlik elektron
sayıları toplamı 6 etti Gördüğün gibi
eğer böyle olursa bu x bu y bu Z olduğu
için Y'ye 2A grubu denk geliyor yani
Toprak alkali metalidir ifadesi
Kesinlikle doğru oluyor bu çok güzel bir
soru olmuş cevap 3 ve 4 oldu yani D
seçeneği dostum Haydi bakalım dinlenme
vakti geldi güzel sorular çözdük ne
yaptık atom yarıçapından ve iyonlaşma
enerjisinden bahsetmiş olduk şöyle
kısaca hatırlayalım atom yarıçapın neye
dikkat ediyorduk önce katman sayısı
katman sayısı büyük olanın çapı büyüktü
eğer aynı katman sayısına sahiplere
proton sayısı küçük olanın çapı büyüktü
Bir de ne demiştik elektron aldığında
çap artıyordu elektron verdiğinde çap
azalıyordu demiştik sonra iyonlaşma
enerjisi dedik Gaz halindeki Nötr bir
atomdan bir elektron kopardığımız
birinci iyonlaşma enerjisi oluyordu + 1
yüklen bir elektron kopardığımız da
ikinci iyonlaşma enerjisi o şekilde
gidiyordu ve her seferinde iyonlaşma
enerjisi bir öncekine göre daha büyük
oluyordu Yani birinci iyonlaşma yisi en
küçük sonra ne oluyordu 2 ikinci
iyonlaşma yisi daha büyük üçüncü daha
büyük öyle gidiyordu sonra ne bakıyorduk
artışlara bakıyorduk birbirini takip
eden artışlara bakarak ne yapıyorduk
Grup numarasını belirleyebiliyorsunuz
belirleyebiliyorsunuz
vardı 2A 3A danan büyüktü 5A da 6 A'dan
büyüktü neden küresel simetri özelliği
olduğu için küresel simetri kararlılık
veriyordu sonra eğer aynı gruptayız neye
bakıyorduk Çapa bakıyorduk yani katman
sayısına katman sayısı küçük olanın yani
çapı küçük olanın iyonlaşma enerjisi
daha büyüktür yorumunu yapıyorduk Dostum
Evet bunları hatırlamış olduk Sen de ne
yapıyorsun şimdi soru çözerek tekrar
ediyorsun ödevlendirme beleri Biliyorsun
oradan devam et ödevini bitir sonra gel
kaldığımız yerden devam edelim iki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça
kal an